entrepreneur Mark Cuban never calls time
out I always look at business as a sport
and football you play 60 minutes
basketball you play 48 minutes in
business
it's 24 by 7 by 365 and the whole
world's trying to kick your ass I will
never forget talking to mark about you
know where are you going with this
broadcast thing and he goes I'm going to
the BBC billionaire boys club
Mark Cuban parlayed his passion for
Indiana basketball into a company worth
five point seven billion dollars the day
that broadcast.com was sold to Yahoo I
think a lot of folks felt like we had
hit the lottery twice the unorthodox
entrepreneur has disrupted every
business he touched he said never blow
the stuff this is not what I want rip
everything I always start again
he's been slammed eliminated and
investigated Mark Cuban order to appear
before the SEC but almost always comes
out on top he is smart being one of the
smartest people but he goes ooh you
could make the argument it was one of
the luckiest people in the age of the
Internet somebody has got to be the
luckiest person in the world nobody's
got it
it appears that they are facility
game-by-game basis but I can't feel -
Mark Cuban got in at the beginning of
the internet boom and it served him well
his gold mine was called broadcast comm
one of the first internet sites to
stream events live everything from
Victoria's Secret models to countless
sporting events we were the first ones
to scale internet broadcasting you know
to take five hundred radio stations and
broadcast them on the Internet a hundred
television stations earnings calls
product launches college football games
deals with the NHL Major League Baseball
mean we had really become a broadcast
network on the Internet the fiercely
independent entrepreneur has blazed a
trail into TV movies NBA ownership and
he even stars on a TV show
though he declined to participate in
this one mark has been an entrepreneur
from the moment the word was invented
before it meant drug deal
Mark Cuban was born in Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania and grew up in a suburb
called Mount Lebanon from the get-go
Cuban was a money maker selling trash
bags newspapers and even postage stamps
I started a stamp company I started with
a quarter and bought a stamp and left
with $50 thinking hey if I could do this
I could do anything by the time he was
16 he had already built a reputation
Brian Cuban is his younger brother I
remember mark being given $5,000 by one
of our neighbors to go buy stamps in New
York with my father now he was always
the entrepreneur a stamp shows but that
just shows you at that age what people
thought of his ability to make money
that skill only grew at Indiana
University the tireless business major
taught disco started a chain letter and
decided to run a bar if he could come up
with $15,000 Evan Williams was an
engineer at General Motors who played on
the school rugby club with Mark Cuban he
was at my house one day he was calling
banks to try to get a loan so I could
buy this bar so on my way out said hey
mark if you have any problems getting
that loan just give me a call two days
later he goes hey EV so I ended up late
1979 loaning mark fifteen thousand
dollars so he could buy a bar in
Bloomington Kuban awarded Williams stock
certificate number one and within months
opened his bar Motley's Wayne Winston
teaches graduate statistics at Indiana
University in my over 35 years of
teaching I've never had a student really
start a business while they were an
undergrad or an MBA here on campus and
he started Motley's which became by far
I think the best bar in town the
business model he used in Motley's is
very close to the same business models
he used in his next two or three
businesses he always would have 51% of
it even though he didn't put up any of
his own money but no one really
complained because he was the one that
built up the business until it came
crashing down
after a wet t-shirt contest it's pretty
common knowledge around town and
underage girl won a wet t-shirt contest
and so I think that hurt the future of
the bar let's put it that way
Kuban graduated and soon landed in
Dallas within a year the born
entrepreneur launched micro solutions
providing software hardware and training
to businesses at the dawn of the PC
revolution it was a family affair
Marko's you come work for me so I said
fine so my first day at work you're not
a big lawyer I show up with my suit and
tie and he goes why are you wearing that
well you know come to work for you at
micro solutions no go home and change
put on crappy clothes and your jeans
you're in the stockroom mark doesn't
give you anything you have to learn it
and earn it
Mark Cuban learned the computer business
fast and in seven years sold his company
to CompuServe for six million dollars I
retired and you retired and what did you
do with that money your biggest purchase
my biggest purchase I bought a lifetime
pass on American Airlines and I had one
mission in mind I wanted to be already
go to as many countries around the world
as I could and get drunk with as many
people as I possibly could and I was so
good
in 1995
Mark Cuban came out of early retirement
to reinvent radio
according to Cuban college friend Todd
Wagner brought him the concept it's a
story that Hoosiers basketball fan has
told often as in this interview on 60
minutes
he sat me down he said look I've got
this idea where I think we can listen to
Indiana basketball sporting events you
know anywhere in the world by using the
Internet so mark and I just basically
said let's find out if this is a
business or not so we set up shop in his
upstairs bedroom of his house and you
know got us a computer got the software
and started playing with it and that is
the birth of audio net what eventually
became broadcast comm but another young
entrepreneur tells a different story
Chris jabe says he was also a founder of
the company when I was pretty young I
was a Minnesota Twins fan I moved to
Texas oh it's a displaced fan I was
always trying to figure out how to get
access to those games that I couldn't
see on regular TV when the internet came
along it's like it was a slam dunk
because now it was just a matter of
querying broadcast rights
he took his plan to investors one of
them was Cuban I probably had this pitch
dyed given to maybe 150 people over the
previous year and a half to two years
and so I'm getting into my pitch this
shoots about a 20-minute pitch and
within three minutes he goes I'm in I'll
do it Jeb asked for a million dollars
and said that Cuban wrote a check for
10,000 and months later tried to cut him
out completely mark said Chris I really
don't need you you really don't have
that much to add I can pretty much do or
get people to do what you're doing so I
was a little bummed to say the least and
I really give Todd a lot of credit when
he came to me and said you know we can
work a deal with you know for 2,500 a
month and 10% of the company in the way
he described it in the Ray he showed me
the paperwork I knew it was real and it
really made me feel really good actually
even though it was hard to take 10% of a
company that I developed 100% from
scratch cuban became the driving force
of audio net mark overall really wanted
to see it as his company he had made it
gone from really
idea to reality he never really want to
acknowledge me as a founder but
co-founder Todd Wagner does acknowledge
Jeb's participation he was there for a
very brief period of time and then he
went on to the next thing he owned the
slug of equity and did just fine audio
net did better than just fine you go
back in there and all they did was have
all these servers with all these
different sporting events going on and
people trying to keep the server's up
virtually what is going on in here
they're planning a nuclear strike you
know but it was controlled chaos and
they're keeping all those servers up and
all the game streaming it was pretty
cool
Kuban and Wagner changed the name from
audio net to broadcast comm in 1998 and
positioned the company to go public the
internet boom was in full swing and on
July 17th the stock hit the market
priced at $18 a share the first trade
pops up and it was you know $63 or
whatever it was I mean it was just
through the roof nada Oh Cena led the
sports properties and marketing
departments at the company I recall our
head of HR popping her head out of a
cube like a game of whack-a-mole and
saying we opened at whatever the number
was and everyone looked up and we
thought she missed by a decimal she must
be wrong and we all started a look and
you could just see heads popping out and
the excitement in the room it was
literally like a parade went off the
stock closed at 60 to 75 at the time
it's set a record for the highest
percentage increase on an opening day
I'm the first to realize that luck plays
a huge part in it I happen to have a
company broadcast comm that went public
at the right time when the internet
stock market was going nuts
Cuban wanted to expand their content and
was looking for a breakout event he
founded in lingerie there were a lot of
pinnacle events for broadcast comm and
one of those was certainly the
Victoria's Secret webcast
rapping high-tech with high-fashion the
webcast was a phenomenon
millions of people tuned in and it
became the largest viewed event ever on
the web we like to position it as the
first sold-out event on the Internet it
helped to cement us as the go-to place
if you wanted to do something multimedia
on the Internet
Jeff Sweeney is an entrepreneur and
friend of Cubans from Dallas I will
never forget talking to Marc about you
know where are you going with this
broadcast thing and he goes I'm going to
the BBC billionaire boys club you're not
gonna make a billion dollars on this
thing I mean you're gonna make one
hundred million dollars no no no dude no
BBC dude that's what I'm doing in
pursuit of that billion Cuban and Wagner
led the charge straight to the executive
offices of Yahoo I remember mark and I
going into the conference room and
basically just saying look we're where
you guys need to be so you're either
gonna have to compete with us or you're
gonna have to buy us because we are big
players in what we think the Internet's
gonna go Yahoo
felt the breadth of competition
according to Paul Sappho a leading
technology forecaster it's a moment
where there's a sense of the rise of the
machines algorithms the form of Google
are really taking over the search space
and it's beginning to dawn on people
that in fact there is a lot of
volatility and customer loyalty around
place as you visit on the web I can
remember going to Yahoo and you could
just feel the anxiety at the company how
do we bulk up our technology side
looking for an answer in April 1999
Yahoo grabbed broadcast.com for a
staggering sum 5.7 billion dollars in
stock the deal secured Cubans membership
in that billionaires Club
I think a lot of folks felt like we had
hit the lottery twice you had this
tremendous IPO and to top it off one of
the the great companies in Silicon
Valley Yahoo
comes in and acquires this little old
company that was set up in Deep Ellum
Dallas Texas it couldn't have been
frankly scripted any better but not
scripted all that well for Yahoo it is
so easy to quarterback this thing and as
people say it's one of the stupidest
moves in the history of the internet but
there was so much stupidity in that
period it was like a single note in a
vast symphony of stupidity yahoo
struggled with their new acquisition
it's pretty simple to see what happened
if you're on the inside you had a five
billion dollar acquisition handed to a
number of NBA's who had never actually
integrated anything before we ah who
really took a pounding they took their
eye off the ball of search which opened
the door for Google who smoked them
within months of the buyout Kuban
protected a stock by buying puts and
calls against his interest and began to
cash out buying a twenty four thousand
square foot mansion and a forty 1
million dollar jet but his next purchase
would be the billionaire's prized
possession
you
in January 2000 sports fanatic Mark
Cuban bought majority ownership in the
Dallas Mavericks from Ross Perot jr. it
was the crowning purchase for the
billionaire with the insatiable desire
to win except that the franchise had one
of the worst win-loss records of any
team in the NBA you've gotta start
giving these guys who have been in
damage programs let's call him the
thought process that they can win that
they are expected to win Cuban was going
to change everything his way
terr Dima Ussery the buttoned-up CEO of
the Dallas Mavericks recalled his first
meeting I didn't need the whole day
because we're having dinner at his house
that night and I want to be a great
guest and I was in suit and tie and you
know tell my Sunday best is my mom
called it he opened doors and jeans and
no shoes him t-shirt and we sat on this
floor and watch basketball for four or
five hours and eight I think anything
was cocoa puffs
and Doritos is what we had in bottled
waters so it was it was just a new
reality that new reality took effect the
moment Cubans saw the traditional wood
paneled locker room in the Mavericks new
arena he said you've got to blow this up
this is not what I want I want a law of
come on open ceilings I want the guys to
fly kits a clubhouse the place they hang
out and we got to get a pool table in
here and we got to get the DVDs rip
everything out and start again in the
clubhouse the radical new owner booked
first-class hotels for road games and
went by a team jet with legroom for
seven footers all that stuff was noon
none of that stuff had been done in the
league before nor had an owner worn a
Mavs fan for life t-shirt or put his
email address on the jumbotron or broken
custom by ditching the skybox for
courtside seats and yelling at the
referees
mark is the plenty that's gotten him in
trouble
Scot sosnick reports on sports business
for Bloomberg News my favorite one is
when he said that a referee wasn't
qualified to manage a Dairy Queen but
when he said that Dairy Queen got upset
but they wanted mark to know what their
managers were highly trained highly
skilled folks and so the guy challenged
mark to come down and serve ice cream
and to see how difficult it really was
there were probably six helicopters
hovering above at this poor Dairy Queen
there were probably 3,000 people outside
and he was there additional ice cream
he's a very very smart marketing guy and
if he can turn a negative into a
positive he will but Cubans courtside
criticism was a negative for David Stern
the longtime Commissioner of the NBA I
think mark was very impatient when he
first became an owner because he strives
for perfection and he expressed his
views in that regard it wasn't a
constructive enterprise to publicly
criticize our officials and it's
prohibited by our rules those rules
resulted in Cubans first fine of $5,000
followed by fines of 15,000 25,000
250,000 100,000 10,000 and 100,000 again
all in his first full season as an owner
my job is to stand up for my my guys
enough I think something's wrong I'm
gonna do something about it
reporter John Swartz followed Cubans
career for 13 years that connects with
people you don't see that among many
billionaires they think they have to act
a certain way now that he cares I think
you honestly just could give a damn what
anyone thinks about him Cubans hands-on
involvement brought immediate success
attendance shot up more than 35% the
estimated teen value left fifty million
dollars and the Mavericks went to the
playoffs in 2001 for the first time in
over ten years
before he owned the Dallas Mavericks
they were the laughingstock of the NBA
they were winning 15 games a year once
he took over their winning percentages
got to be one of the best it's done
being the top five
despite their surging success that year
the Mavericks fell short of the
championship and success for Cuban in
the film and TV business was also
proving elusive at the dawn of HDTV in
2001 he launched the first
high-definition television network
called HD net as he explained to Charlie
Rose we're available on cable were
available on satellite but viewers can
go knowing that not only they're gonna
get great entertainment but they're
gonna get great entertainment and the
best possible picture quality the
network sputtered barely reaching
350,000 homes in its first year Cuban
hit pause long enough to marry longtime
girlfriend Tiffany Stewart throwing a
reception bash on his home court the
American Airlines Center by 2003 he
reteamed with Todd Wagner and plunged
into the movie business
we bought Landmark Theatres which was a
national independent theater chain we
invested and then bought Magnolia
Pictures a theatrical distribution
company we built on a home entertainment
unit as well to that and all of a sudden
we had built a vertically integrated
media company meaning with production
distribution and exhibition all under
one roof in a way that frankly we had
not seen done before it gave Cuban the
pieces to shake up the movie business by
releasing a film in theaters on DVD and
TV simultaneously Andy fix mer is an
entertainment reporter for Bloomberg
News back then nobody was doing this
nobody even thought that you would dare
put a movie on television before it was
released in theaters it just wasn't done
Cubans movies met with mixed success
some films like good night and good luck
had found critical acclaim and a niche
audience while others struggled and
there was a disappointment again on the
basketball court star Dirk Nowitzki led
the team into the finals in 2006 the
Mavs were up two games to none when
momentum
suddenly shifted and the team dropped
three straight Cuban was livid when he
was pissed he may as well have been
Satan the players literally ran the
other way in the locker room after their
collapse in the championship Nowitzki
publicly called for Cuban to control his
temper for the owner who hated to lose
the loss was pure devastation
I believe he didn't leave the house for
three weeks and he became a shut-in so
what did it cost him it cost him his
dream really his dream was to turn the
Mavericks into Champions
Mark Cuban the former disco teacher
returned to dancing in 2007 in front of
millions
mark likes as much air time as he can
get as long as it's fun and it's
entertainment for him he's going to do
it
he appeared on almost anything even
hosting his own reality show the
benefactor canceled after one season
viewers were also in short supply on his
own network with it's strange blend of
bikini themed programming mixed martial
arts and dan Rather
dan Rather and Dan Rather reports on
HDNet is kind of my own personal
indulgence you know I'm a news junky and
always have been
dan Rather was doing his show for them
which was actually very good but the
rest of it was just like a Sargasso Sea
of just crap Cuban had more troubles
looming the Securities and Exchange
Commission filed a suit against him we
return now to the crackdown on insider
trading and it has ensnared billionaire
the SEC alleged that Cuban dumped
600,000 shares of mama calm as an
insider trade the 2008 lawsuit from the
SEC says he sold shares the company
ahead of the company's own plans to sell
more discounted shares to investors and
avoided three-quarters of a million
dollars worth of losses on his blog
Cuban stated the claims were false the
suit was dismissed in District Court but
the SEC appealed and the case was
reinstated in 2010
while Cuban battled in the courtroom he
also prepared for battle on the
basketball court
he dealt for key players hired a new
coach and in 2011 the Mavericks fought
their way back to the fighters
surprising everyone the loudmouth behind
the team bench went silent it was
different I mean still people went up
and talked to him but he said not today
not me talk to the players with Mark in
the background it was this other guy
Dirk Nowitzki and the team that Mark had
assembled that in the end was able to
live off what he's always dreamed of
we've had the ceremony inside the
building and all of a sudden chant broke
out thank you Mark
thank you Mark thank you mark how many
times have you heard of a building
chanting thank you to the owner that's
pretty unique with a championship banner
finally in place
Cuban rebranded HDNet calling it access
TV in addition to Ryan Seacrest Cuban
partnered with two of the most powerful
names in music and entertainment he
lives in Dallas with his wife and three
children on his personal blog he sounds
off on everything from executive
compensation to personal health weather
brilliant are just plain lucky Mark
Cuban will always be looking for his
next big move is going to challenge
conventions he's gonna change how people
think he's definitely a guy to always
keep your eye on he's brash he's not
afraid of controversy but he's also one
of the most brilliant strategic thinkers
I've ever met is the glass of water
half-full or half-empty Mark's gonna be
the guy asking whose porn you can look
at things and say this is the way
they've always been done I like to look
at and said well if everybody's doing
this way that's not where the future is
you have to look somewhere else and you
know if that pisses people off that's
their problem